on est en ligne avec olga en shahrukh
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
sur sur france 24 il est une heure de
plus
à kiev il est 18 heures la tour de la
télévision a été bombardé par par les
frappes a été bombardé par les russes
pardon est ce que vous avez encore accès
aux communications que se passe-t-il
actuellement autour de vous
autour de 90 ans qu'on tire dégrade mais
c'est il me semble que ce sont les
nôtres c'est en en troupe qui peut qui
essayent de
arrêté oui d'arrêter les russes parce
que nous sommes bloqués ici de tous
côtés oui nous nous sommes bloqués dans
notre village parce que notre route qui
traverse notre village notre route
principale
elle mène à la capitale et on a bloqué
toutes les routes pour
empêcher les russes de pénétrer dans la
capitale est maintenant de sont bloqués
entre le réservoir drop une grande de
voir doc est construit sur le niveau
entre kiev la capitale et entre les
troupes russes vous êtes actuellement
en banlieue de kiev c'est tout près de
quille c'est 18 km et
oui oui et bien sûr il ya le couvre-feu
est de 20 kilomètres de nous se trouvent
déjà les russes les animaux donc vous
entendez les russes vous savez qu'ils
sont là vous les voyez aussi
oui on entend très bien on entend très
bien les tirs on voit que vous êtes dans
le noir c'est à dire que c'est compliqué
d'avoir de l'électricité actuellement la
dans la banlieue de kiev
non chez nous dans notre village il n'y
a pas de problème avec l'électricité
mais je sais que à 20 kilomètres de nous
les gens n'ont plus ni électricité ni
chauffage ni l'homme
comment comment vous vivez depuis depuis
jeudi comment vous organisez pour pour
la vie quotidienne est ce qu'il ya des
pénuries fin comment ça se passe votre
vie depuis depuis jeudi mais on essaie
de soutenir les uns les autres parce que
nos hommes et des six sont engagés dans
la milice pour protéger notre village et
les femmes il reste avec les enfants
mois notamment j'ai un petit bébé de
11 mois et je passe
les jours avec mes voisins et on essaie
de préparer leur ai pas fait le ménage
pour soutenir les hommes louis pour leur
donner à manger ou
préparer les vêtements et les hommes ils
sont toujours il protège le village
alors vous êtes originaire de la région
du donbass une région où l'eau est la
guerre depuis 2014 puisque laquelle
l'ukraine connaît déjà la guerre depuis
2014 une région qui a reconnu que la dmr
poutine il ya quelques jours est-ce que
vous avez des nouvelles de vos proches
sur place ah oui j'ai de nouvelles pour
le moment c'est seulement mon père qui
reste là bas parce qu'il est médecin et
il ne peut pas quitter il ne veut pas
quitter
notre ville natale et comme je dis il y
a quelques jours que ma mère avant juste
avant la guerre elle est repartie à la
conférence médicale à l'ukraine
occidentale et le reste là bas parce que
les trains sont annulés à la destination
de john bass et ne peut pas venir ni
acquis et venir d'une base est ce que
vous pensez à quitter le pays comme près
de 700 mille autres ukrainiens qui l'ont
déjà fait là qui font la queue dans la
voiture qui attendent parfois 50 60
heures pour pouvoir traverser la
frontière avec la pologne est ce que
vous vous pensé à partir non non non
j'ai pas un spa ça
tout d'abord parce que je veux rester
si on veut te dire comme ça jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à notre victoire parce que je
suis sûr que
nous allons combattre les russes avec le
soutien que tout le tout le monde le
monde inquiète nos portes nous donne
notamment la france 6
et je veux rester avec mon mari avec mon
fils ici mais deuxièmement parce que
c'est dangereux et de notre région de
notre village
n'était pas l'évacuation parce que c'est
trop dangereux sur les routes vous vous
sans vous voyez l'élan de solidarité qui
est un peu partout dans le monde par
exemple à l'assemblée nationale
française tout à l'heure les députés
avaient un badge aux couleurs de
l'ukraine on a applaudi longuement
l'ukraine tout le monde soutient ukraine
ça vous aide aussi bien sûr même les
honneurs des ennemis français qui
propose l'aide financière ouled
autre type dead et le ils écrivent
toujours elle me soutient beaucoup et
c'est très important pour nous bien sûr
comment vous voyez l'avenir algayon de
char ou comment vous voyez l'avenir là
dans les prochains jours
mais j'espère bien sûr que
la guerre va s'arrêter mais je vois je
suis réaliste je vois que d'une bassesse
et dure déjà depuis huit ans je pense
que on n'était pas compter sur cela que
ce sera très vite arrêté parce qu'on a
quand nos connaissances russe de crime
et quand ils nous appellent j'espérais
beaucoup que les russes pouvaient
arrêter c'est une vision mais après les
conversations avec je vois qu'ils ne
comprennent rien pour lé moment qu'est
le bélarus il ne comprend rien et c'est
pourquoi il n'y a pas d'histoire qu'ils
vont arrêter ça qu'ils vont
arrêter leur président fou complètement
fou merci beaucoup a legal gontcharov
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
pour nous parler de cette vie
quotidienne à côté de kiev dans la
banlieue de kiev merci pour votre
témoignage on